James Doohan one of the most fantastic
series that is possibly around at the
moment getting the Thrones everybody
loves it
tell me a little bit what you enjoy
about being it as an actor and playing
your character well I think one of the
joys of being in Game of Thrones is the
the richness and the characterization of
the whole show Lord Mormont who I play
in the show wonderfully complex normal
old character
the huge backstory and that's the thing
there George writes were such meticulous
attention to the back history makes
everything really interesting for an
actor so yeah it's it's some
many-faceted it's terrific working how
do you find getting to grips with all
that backstory did you say there's so
much there with Lord Mormont isn't there
yeah there is and you you have to almost
a cut away a bit of it you know and just
work with the script that you have but
it's great just to read a bit of it and
then so you know where the guys coming
from
although the audience doesn't you do you
know so it's it's fascinating and not
often do you get that in a television
situation you know where there's so much
material to source from it should you
come back to the books there I mean I
wonder how much ahead to you keep what
you try and keep just where your
character is in the TV series would you
want to kind of tantalize yourself with
when you might be going no I just stick
to where the character is at that point
you know because I think it might muddy
the water a bit you know if you see well
this is gonna happen that's gonna happen
you know I think it's best just to keep
keep abreast of it what have you enjoyed
most about playing Lord Marmont so far
what his particular scenes and memorable
moments he's had on the small screen
a couple of times at the very beginning
when he's introducing them all to the
the Nights Watch that was a pretty
awesome scene really enjoyed that and
I'd really enjoyed filming in Iceland
which is amazing if extremely cold but
it is astonishing it's a beautiful
beautiful country how long were you out
there and what did you enjoy about being
there most I was like we were out there
for a couple of weeks and just the
isolation and the purity of the place
and it suits the story so wonderfully
because that pristine snowbound
landscape you know where things die if
they're not you know completely warm
it's amazing
what are you looking forward to
happening in season 3 and what are you
looking forward to us actually seeing on
the screen I think there's going to be a
terrific season it's going to be the
best yet because everything really kicks
off you know and obviously I can't say
what's going to happen but it's going to
be very exciting and very surprising is
that something you like as an actor
continually surprising the audience well
not so much me but I think HBO and
George Martin the way they have managed
to Leonor look with with Sean Bean at
the beginning that that everyone
followed you know he's the lead is the
main storyline and then he dies it's a
terribly clever way of wrong footing the
audience so they have to immediately
start looking for someone else to follow
if you were picking one of the other
characters who's you kind of your
favorite in the series a moment apart
from the Lord moment obviously here we
do say oh I think Peters English part
you know whose is tremendous in it you
know but it must be great fun to play
really great fun but nearly every
character in the whole book has as
interesting there's no there's no
you know one-dimensional characters and
that stuff you know tremendous work you
get to hang out with the guys offset a
little bit and if so what you get up to
what's the atmosphere like on set
well obviously you only work with the
people that are in your storyline you
know so people say oh how does it like
working with such I've never seen him
never met him you know because they are
in Croatia or Morocco and I'm in Belfast
you know but yeah and the days are quite
long when you're working so it's a
serious job you know but we all
appreciate that we're in a a wonderful
show that will go on and and be
remembered for many years so it's
everybody's got a pretty positive
feeling about it what's it like when
you're in Belfast filming and obviously
it's all part of the magic of TV and
film isn't it but then you're kind of
bringing this whole different world so
there's more screen yeah and where the
wall is just that same Belfast looks
tremendous you know can't tell you the
first time you arrived there you know
and you just say oh there's another
television show you walk on and we see
the wall it's astonishing you know and
he really I've been in the business 45
years now and I was blown away by it so
that's saying events like if you weren't
even in the show you'd be a huge fan of
it as well absolutely absolutely it's a
great piece of work and HBO they seem to
to know exactly what they're doing every
single time every sure they do is just
on the money it's a great company to
work for what do you think we couldn't
look forward to happening in terms of
the number of series that we're gonna
have because obviously know who how many
books there are that obviously were on
season three at the moment well I
believe that because of the incredible
popularity of the show that they maybe
it was one season one book
but no there may be because there's so
much in every book they can quite easily
put two seasons into one book you know
they just make it richer and opener out
and the audience will love it even more
so I wouldn't be surprised not one of
the longest-running shows I would say
maybe could be eight ten years I think
fantastic wouldn't it it really would
yeah yeah but it's I think it's one of
these programs that would never they
would they would cut it before it ever
became stale but I think there's so much
there that's not gonna happen I can't
actually ever imagine Game of Thrones
becoming a style is such a fan base for
there as well yeah yeah and there's so
much attention to detail to -
translating George Martin's work to the
screen and the the technical staff and
the directors so meticulous yeah it'll
be always be a great show that nobody's
ever going to be disappointed in Game of
Thrones in terms of things like
production design and costumes they've
got it beautifully done I mean it's an
actor how does that help inform your
acting your role night Lord Mormont
makes a huge difference you know when
when you can get into a costume that
feels right that you know that someone's
put a lot of time and effort
read the books knows exactly why he
would be wearing this how we would feel
in this how how they would be in the
cold what everything about it is
everyone's working so hard to put
together what's on the screen because
all the money's on the screen it's great
is there anything that surprised you so
far about Lord Mormont or anything
that's happened in the show you thought
gosh I wasn't expecting that to happen
no because I was I was sort of aware of
what moment was and where he was going
you know so I was very secure in in his
character and
just couldn't wait to go on and start
doing it and what do fans normally kind
of talk to you about when they when they
come and talk to you events like
comic-con and why do they like more
money baby
I think Mormons has the fans seem to
think that Mormon has a great deal of
them gravitas and dignity
he's a he's a very anchoring so a
character provides all these young men
with us of all the role model and he's a
great guy he's a type of guy who would
like to leave an army you trust him and
you feel that you play that role in the
cast as well a little bit oh I don't
know about that I'm a bad boy in the
choir what have you been getting it to
you lately there's nothing a bit
gardening now I'm too busy to do
anything thank goodness it's finally are
there any particular scenes that you've
enjoyed working with other the stars in
the show this season in particular I
always liked working with the younger
members of the cast we have a lot of fun
doing that you know and seeing them
struggling up glaciers and falling over
provides me with a great deal of math do
you think yeah I'm not doing that yeah
way to log in the tooth to do that
fantastic and anything else you'd like
to say to the game with rowing fans out
there just I'm so glad that they're all
enjoying it it's a real pleasure and
privilege to be part of the show and
keep watching thank you
you